[Music]
through everybody oh yeah happy happy
Thursday everybody uh what a short week
it is as you probably already know
California has a reparations task force
and what's their task besides giving
government employees something to do
between renaming elementary schools
after marxists and handing out syringes
it lets them punish citizens for crimes
committed before they were born against
people they don't know in places most of
them have never even been to you know
that's like punishing me because in the
past one of my relatives bought a Red
Hot Chili Peppers record
yeah
I can't hell be held accountable for
every white person's atrocity
the task force just released a report of
over a thousand pages and it's all about
quote eliminating disparities you know
like the one between people who own
small businesses and people who loot
small businesses like between people who
use a bathroom and people and people who
pee behind trash cans
hahaha
it was one time yes
and it's on tape the main recommendation
of course is reparations they want to
give up to 1.2 million to each eligible
California resident to make up for their
ancestors being enslaved in other states
basically replacing policy with
Powerball how in the world would that
even work where would the money come
from why should an Asian family that
just moved to America be forced to pay
for a bad thing that happened 150 years
ago and as you know origin stories they
could be problematic
Barack Obama descendant of slave owners
Donald Trump not a descendant of slave
owners
John fetterman who's he a descendant of
you can see how it gets confused and I
mean does Joy Behar pay reparations when
whatever she descended from no longer
exists
luckily for Hillary Clinton whomever she
descended from is still very very
powerful
foreign
but that's just the beginning the task
force has also called on the state
legislature to cancel child support debt
for black residents yes yeah
you're not in California Tyrus
I identify
so does that help well whoever owes the
debt but who doesn't hurt whoever needs
that support if it weren't for white
liberals black families might actually
succeed more but here's my favorite
policy recommendation I'm just going to
read this as is quote law enforcement is
frequently tasked with enforcing public
disorder offenses such as illegal
camping public intoxication disorderly
conduct minor trespass and my favorite
public urination
although the subjects of these contacts
are often experiencing homelessness a
mental health crisis or both the
responding officers typically possess
neither training or expertise in working
with these vulnerable populations and
this disconnect often results in the use
of excessive and sometimes fatal force
that falls disproportionately on black
individuals given the devastating
impacts of this kind of over policing
they recommend that the legislature
prohibit law enforcement from criminally
enforcing public disorder infractions
and other low-level crimes
there you have it don't enforce the law
because the guy breaking the law might
be black
and boy that's a lot of unenforced law
but it's weird all of these ideas to
help black Californians always sound
really racist forgive child support debt
let people pee on the street I mean what
liberal came up with these David Duke
Joe Biden
hard to tell meanwhile if you're just
trying to mind your own business raise a
family or work you still got to pay
taxes but with the added value people
literally pissing on you
California's been home to a lot of awful
things earthquakes fires the Manson
family 20 seasons of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
but slavery was never one of them and
yet they're using that past evil to
create a present divide that only the
very rich and the Very protected can
endure you know the old phrase don't
piss on my leg and tell me it's raining
the left doesn't even bother to lie
anymore now they'll just piss on you and
call you racist for complaining
[Applause]
all right let's welcome tonight's guests
Bears play dead around her oh to the Fox
Nation series luxury hunting Lodges of
America
Katie Pavlich
[Applause]
he's the only guy who asks how you'd
like your terrorist cooked foreign
military intelligence analyst Brett
villagovic
she's like popcorn light salty and
always popping off Fox News contributor
cat tip
and for him a big gulp is half a Big
Gulp my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
so Tyrus it looks like we're rolling
with the itches
you got pavlets and villaconovitovic
we're rolling with the itches very
clever yes I like how you did that yeah
it's a little word play to start off the
Thursday night does this stuff bother
you because like it's like all the like
it's not just pissing in public it's
like trespassing it bothers me in the
sense that it's like
I'm at a family reunion picnic and
there's like there's those two uncles in
the back that do dump every year
and those are the only ones they put on
the family poster
the rest of us are doing our part
we work we pay our taxes but apparently
me getting up and going to the toilet is
just too much to ask so I'll just go yes
thank you it's a poor thing it's it's
not a black thing and the but it's so
easy to make it a black thing when
you're trying to accomplish something
that's stupid if you put race in front
of it the average virtue signaling
Liberal oh well we need to make sure
that I didn't know the Negroes were
having a hard time going to your urinal
it is confusing I mean there's a cake in
there I hope God I hope the poor things
didn't eat us yes you know because they
can't do anything without us they'd be
lost
yellow yellow yeah they just sit around
don't touch that yeah
see that's the problem but uh but that's
the
ugliness of it if you put black in front
of it everyone's like oh we have to do
it it's insulting the only thing that I
would even merely consider was forgiven
child support although
because it'd be nice to be able to put
my money towards my kids where I want it
to be right besides paying for the
University of Phoenix to their New Lover
yeah
that was very specific
was it
for the kids but it would be nice that
that I would be nice but other than that
it's insulting Katie do you find a
urination lost sexist it's really about
men no it's not like a lot of women
urinate in public as far as my cameras
show I mean I think it depends on which
state you're in in California literally
uh last time I was in California I
watched a man sucking on his own toe on
the beach for a very very long time glad
you said yeah and we may wanted to make
sure he had pants on so that was a good
thing he would suck it on his own toe
his own toe for a long time and you know
if he was stressed out there was
something happening
um but if public urination is going to
be legal as if it's not already in
California I just kept thinking about
how dirty that toe really was
pretty gross so this is why people are
leaving California and this is why this
show is moving to 10 P.M
because we need to get this kind of
subject matter earlier on so we're on at
seven o'clock in California when you're
enjoying your uh Polish sausage
[Laughter]
why would that get Applause
oh there you go they're polish
wow
Brad I'm scared Brett uh your hair looks
great you shaved your beard I almost
didn't recognize you yeah yeah nice look
for me man yeah yeah what do you make of
this whole business like associating
this this basically like Behavior with
reparations makes no sense to me I don't
know I think this reparations task force
is a bit of a scam like I hope people
like realize it's such a joke like what
does this P You're a nation law even
have to do with slavery which is like
what the original you know intention for
this reparations task force you know
that's the whole reason it was there to
do that and it's just it's just absurd
like the best part about it is they're
actually saying that people are going if
you're getting get prosecuted for
urinating in public people owe you money
so now we're like funding bad behavior
we're funding criminality it's just
absurd well you know it's funny though
because Kat you have sold your urine
before
not yet not yet no actually I've bought
urine uh whenever I have a drug test
well maybe this is a new sport yes you
know a pissing contest yes yeah they can
raise money yeah charge raise taxes yes
like they have at carnivals yeah except
you don't use the gun to squirt it's
already at freak Show you know this is a
really odd topic for a monologue cat
what's your take on this
okay bring us out of here sure
um I just think that task force is a bit
of a stretch
I don't think they're doing any tasks
yeah I think they're just trying to like
outlib each other because nobody thinks
this yeah nobody's walking around
California like you know what the
problem is
the peeing policy
it's it's too strict yeah yes you know
what I mean that's why people don't
campaign on it when it knew someone's
facing recall it wasn't like vote for
Gavin Newsom pee wherever
New York I mean I don't know if you've
been outside in the summer it seems to
be there's quite a bit of pee on the
streets we don't advertise that and
tourism ads like come to New York and
pee on it you know
the city that never sleeps or cares
where you're peeing like nobody wants
this and nobody is it's just shocking to
even see that they're pretending to want
this which again they're not doing tests
they're sitting around talking all day
about stuff that nobody wants it doesn't
do anybody any good yeah it's racist I
just thought of that just come to New
York we promise all the blacks pee
outside the bathroom's yours
that's racist yeah yeah I missed that
part of MLK speech Yes
I have a dream which and it's also a
reminder of slavery because I'm pretty
sure we didn't get bathroom breaks
that's right man this is yes all right
before we go tickets are available for
my book tour with special guest Tom shy
Louie
we'll be in Clearwater Fort Myers
Providence that's in Rhode Island and
Reading Pennsylvania home of the peanut
bar
I just like saying that if you can't
make it to one of our Live Events you
can check out my virtual event July 27th
at 6 PM for more info go to gutfeld.com
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else